everyone comes to a national park in
africa
and they want to see lions
they are among the most incredible
species
i've ever worked with
[Music]
my name is paula boule i'm a national
geographic explorer
and associate director of lion
conservation for gorongosa national park
in mozambique
[Music]
when we began nothing was known about
how many lions we had
it was all about collecting data to
really put this population
on the map
[Music]
this country endured 16 years of civil
war
and that war was centered in gorongosa
during their time there was a lot of
over hunting
so we lost about 95 of our large mammals
in a very short time
after the war recovery began slowly
and by 2006 the greg carr
foundation and the government of
mozambique forged a long-term plan
to restore this national park to the gym
that it used to be
before over the past decade we've seen a
remarkable recovery of wildlife
populations with the exception of
lions they didn't make a strong comeback
and our research was
specifically to ask why
to be effective in conservation you have
to collect data which will guide you in
the right direction
[Music]
when we first got started we knew we had
to collect
data on how many lions we had how many
females how many males
and what they were eating where they
were ranging
so we collect data using a variety of
techniques
one is we collect spatial data from the
gps satellite colors
so these colors besides pinging with
satellites also have a radio
signal that's pinging off them every
lion with a collar has a unique
number so we can tune in on the dial on
the radio
and actually hear where they are
secondly we use camera traps to collect
data on lions and other species across
the park
we collected so much data that we
launched wildcam gorongosa which allows
anybody with a wi-fi connection to log
on and help us
identify species
in conservation these days you need to
be able to react
fast we don't have time on our side
and thirdly we are actually on the
ground without teams collecting data in
the field
through our data collection we learned
that snares were the biggest threat to
lions
the snare is a piece of wire or a steel
jewel trap
that are set by hunters in the park to
catch
buffalo wartog but incidentally
lions are in these very same places and
they become entrapped
and so we began to intervene
patrols go out and sweep areas clean of
devices that lions and other wildlife
are getting trapped in
they can come back with 20 sometimes
they come back with 200
but they're actually collecting data on
where these snooze and traps are set
because there are patterns
closer to water forced edges closer to
the boundary
so where before snares was such a threat
today
thanks to the lion patrols and data that
we've collected
we've been able to reverse that
we're trend for a couple of very large
lionesses
[Music]
one is very very pregnant and the other
[Music]
has
over the past year we've seen such high
cut production
wherever we look all the lionesses we've
been studying
have cubs
at this point we feel like we're on the
path to recovery
the time is now if we don't act today
in 20 years we could lose lions on this
continent
that's why we care and we believe we can
do something
to better the situation
data collection will always be important
in conservation
new threats will emerge they won't be
the same as threats we encountered five
or ten years ago
they may but in the meantime as we bring
data in we can act on that data and
that's the most important thing for us
[Music]
now
[Music]
you